I think that too many people are
expecting perfection I think too many
people are expecting that this other
human being is going to be able to
perfectly meet all of their needs is
always going to understand them always
be there for them they're not and and
when we go at it from that aspect of
looking for something that no other
human being can give to us of course
you're going to be disappointed I think
there's also I don't know that we value
promises as much maybe as even in my
parents generation when we said to each
other when we stood next to each other
and made promises to each other you know
32 years ago they were promises that we
intended to keep come hell or high water
we were not divorced just wasn't an
option for us I realized that that has
to be true for both people you know if
one of us had only felt that way then of
course it would be easier to get a
divorce but I think when both people
come into a relationship with the idea
of divorce is not an option I am
committed to you I'm making a vow a vow
and I'm not going to break it and we'll
find a way to work this out we've done
marriage counseling we're not
embarrassed or ashamed to talk about
that I would encourage anybody to get
good marriage counseling I would say
surround yourself with friends who also
value their marriage if you hang out
with people who don't value their own
marriage or they don't really see that
marriage should be and all your life
kind of a commitment then you're going
to be around people who aren't
encouraging they're not even working in
their own marriage that way and so
they're going to be more likely to
encourage you to go oh he's such a jerk
dump him or you know what she's not
she's not meeting your needs you you
should find somebody else when you have
those kind of friends it's really hard
to stay committed
so I'd say go in with the idea that
you're gonna stay together for a life
it's a promise and a vow you're gonna
work it out and that you surround
yourself with people who also are very
very committed to their relationships
you